[Music]
good evening I'm Bret Baier we're coming
to you tonight from Los Angeles we'll
talk about the dynamic politics here in
California and speak with the top
Republican and the governor's race so
far in just a few minutes first tonight
though President Trump going after the
Russia collusion investigation again he
says the FBI has been caught in a major
scandal potentially one of the biggest
political uproars in history according
to the president chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
this evening from the North Lawn good
evening John racket evening to you his
critics say President Trump is
overstating the case when he claims that
his campaign may have been spied on but
that's not even slowing the president
who was on a fast boil about what he
says could be a huge political scandal
leaving the White House today President
Trump let fly on what he is now calling
Spygate it looks like a very serious
event but we'll find out when they look
at the documents I think people are
going to see a lot of bad things happen
I hope it's not so because if it is
there's never been anything like it in
the history of our country
president Trump claims the FBI may have
been spying on his campaign after a
confidential informant had contact in
meetings with three Trump campaign
officials Carter page George papadopolis
and Sam Clovis in a meeting Monday
President Trump told Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein and FBI director
Christopher Rea to work out how they
could get documents related to the
informant and the FISA requests to
surveil page two congressional
investigators we now call it spy gate
you're calling it spy gate a lot of bad
things have happened I want them all to
get together they'll sit in the room
hopefully they'll be able to work it out
among themselves at that meeting
tomorrow House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez Government
Oversight Chairman trey Gowdy ed
O'Callahan from the Department of
Justice FBI director Christopher ray and
Director of National Intelligence dan
coats know Democrats invited the Senate
Minority Leader today insisted
congressman Nunez is trying to interfere
with the Russia investigation and put
the blame for that squarely on
Paul Ryan shoulders Vica Ryan is
allowing this to happen it will forever
be a blot on his record he can't be so
afraid of the hard right and the
president that he would allow this kind
of Banana Republic behavior to go
forward congressman Gowdy today said
it's okay with him if Democrats attend I
don't care who comes I'm not a control
of the invite list if you're going to
show up show up with an open mind and
close loops in other words don't leak
like a sieve when we get through with
the meeting the accusations that Spygate
exploded his president Trump was on his
way to Long Island and a law enforcement
roundtable on the murderous gang ms-13
President Trump in a lather about
Democrats criticism of his use of the
word animals to describe gang members
Democrats Nancy Pelosi as an example are
trying to defend ms-13 gang members I
called them animals the other day and I
was met with rebuked they said there are
people got people these are animals and
as North Korea took journalists and a
tour of the nuclear test site it says it
is closing down President Trump again
suggested the date for a summit might
slide someday a date will absolutely
happen it could very well be June 12th
we'll see well no next week and late
today President Trump also weighed in on
the NFL owners decision to require
players who are on the sidelines to
stand for the national anthem the
president telling our Brian Kilmeade in
an interview to air on Fox and Friends
tomorrow that he is happy with the NFL's
decision but not particularly happy
about the fact that the owners will give
the players the opportunity or at least
the option of riding out the national
anthem in the locker room right store on
that a little bit later and maybe even
the sound from the president from that
interview John there is some reporting
tonight that the White House is
considering opening up that meeting to
possibly Democrats as well the
classified intelligence briefing may be
pushing it down a little bit further
from this there
Chuck Schumer has been stating in the
last 24 hours that he thinks that this
should be handled by the so-called gang
of eight leadership in in Congress there
had not been any move toward that but if
this report is correct Brett there could
be some move to get the gang of eight
involved so that would be in addition to
Chairman newness and chairman Gowdy will
run some traps on it and we'll get back
to you just as soon as we can John
Roberts reporting from the White House
John thanks